welcome back to the show guys today we
have three things to talk about we've
got evan luthra
you've never done a paper you've never
researched a phd in black i don't claim
i'm an expert in blockchain i claim i'm
an honorary phd
i wish we could rewind this 15 seconds
ago when you said you are an expert in
blockchain
but i am an expert in the space of
blockchain i've spoken at 50 plus
blockchain events
just recapping the debate recapping
everything that happened i just want to
tell you guys how i felt it went
uh two i'm going to be talking about my
own departure from youtube
[Music]
for a week uh my mind's fried with all
the webinars
all the promises all the fake fake stuff
so
i'm gonna be leaving you guys for a
little while but not without
leaving something behind to keep you
company we'll be talking about that
uh and number three we're gonna be
talking about kevin zane got sued
over the weekend i believe uh and i have
his lawsuit right here we're gonna go
over that so
buckle up boys because we're we're
following up on a lot we got a lot to
talk about
obviously most of it's you know
following up on cases that we've been
building for a while
uh so go ahead and if you want to go
back through our catalog and watch those
videos first we have videos on evan
luther we have videos on
kevin zhang if you want to familiarize
yourself with what's been going on
because i won't be
rehashing too much in this thing but
anyways the first thing i want to talk
about today is uh
the live stream which just went
amazingly the support was amazing uh
the chat's hilarious it's so
entertaining i just love that community
aspect
we get to build together i don't know
personally i feel like i'm getting
better at
making them back up their claims and
when they don't back up their claims
calling them out on it and spending a
little bit of time saying hey you said
this
actually you're also saying this you
know in the case of the steve jobs
things he told me on the phone the day
before that he had never said he had
been mentored by steve jobs
i never said steve jobs was a mentor by
the way and then the day of he tells me
yes in fact he was been toward by steve
jobs first of all is he your mentor or
not let's just answer that question with
yes or no
i think i would like to say yes oh
he was and then tries to loophole his
way out of it right i learn a lot i
learn a lot from a lot of people i've
never talked to but i've seen their
videos i've learned from them
and i would consider them my mentor and
so things like that were things that i
wanted to call out and i
felt like we successfully did but i want
to talk about a few things that you know
i want to follow up on okay
number one is he claimed people in india
they
the people with honorary doctorates they
just call themselves doctors and it must
be a cultural difference that i don't
find that to be uh
particularly acceptable nobody who gets
an honorary doctorate
calls themselves i know a lot of people
in india who
do that maybe it's different in your
side of the world but i know a lot of
people
who have already doctors in india and
they have the word doctor in front of
them
the chat says otherwise okay nobody in
india uses doctor in front of their
names after receiving an
honorary doctorate from someone who's
receiving a doctoral degree here's
another person
absolutely no one also studying for a
doctoral degree so
i don't know if he was just lying there
or he was seriously misinformed
but it's pretty convenient that once
again he seems to be telling on the fly
saying things that benefit him that
actually turn out to be
false the second thing i want to talk
about is this picture i stumbled upon
that i think encapsulates evan luther
for me
it's a picture of him at the world
economic forum the only problem being is
he has photoshopped himself in
and actually if we do a simple crop job
i can photoshop him
you know anywhere where we can photoshop
him with elon musk we can photoshop him
on the moon uh
this photoshop job is so bad just the
background the foreground they're just
it's terrible but i think yeah
for me this encapsulates the debate this
picture right here
so anyways i just wanted to wrap it all
up by saying thank you guys uh
those live streams would not be the same
without you i do them for the community
because i think they're so fun
and uh yeah yeah it was a lot of fun
thanks to him for coming on and kind of
braving it because
bold bold move that's all i have to say
second thing i want to talk about next
week i will not be here i will be on
vacation
taking a break from all the webinars all
the juicy earnings claims uh yeah we're
just not gonna be talking about them
i will be on a beach somewhere maybe in
a mountain maybe on my couch sleeping i
i haven't really decided yet but i will
not be
making videos i'm tired uh i need a
break
me and my wife need a break and so yeah
that's what's happening
but i know what you're thinking stephen
if you're not here who's going to give
me my
daily fix of fake gurus i've actually
prepared
some content for this week that i'm
going to be gone try to build up a
little bit of
a catalog of videos you know to for you
guys
so check that out while i'm gone um but
just know i won't be as responsive to
like messages
and emails and stuff like that just
because i'm gonna be checking out
and finally the third thing i want to
talk about the part you guys have
probably all been waiting for
this lawsuit that kevin's anxious got
hit with i'm going to be reading it i'm
going to be giving my opinion obviously
i'm not going to be
trying to say any facts about it because
we haven't seen all the evidence come
out but
man this is the first real case of a
fake guru that we've called out
being actually sued in a court
you know i've complained for a very long
time about the you know the federal
trade commission not doing enough
to crack down on false advertising you
know these biz ops but
lawyers private practice lawyers may be
coming in to fill up that gap
you know i think they're realizing that
these people have a lot of money you
know i hate
that things are so much about money
sometimes but uh with
the resources required to finish a full
lawsuit that can be dragged up through
the appeals courts
you really do need big payoffs for a
case to be viable
and you know i think lawyers are waking
up to the fact that these people
might be able to provide that enough of
a justification to do it
this is an angle that i hadn't really
considered that could really balance out
some of the really predatory aspects of
business opportunities
e-commerce all this stuff where you see
all these black hat tactics being used
this is a
class action lawsuit going on under the
racketeer influence and corrupt
organizations act and i'm just going to
be covering it for you for you guys so
you guys know what's going on so if you
know we ever see
kevin zhang you know drop off the map
maybe we know why
big things they hit them with is that
the zheng enterprise uses
fraudulent advertisements on facebook
that promote bogus store closing sales
with deceptive pricing to sell plastic
products
falsely represented to be leather
products if you guys have been watching
fake guru we've covered this exactly
dixon leather if you guys don't know was
selling uh
these these leather jackets right uh
real leather
not [ __ ] but when you go and you
look at the complaints
they're not leather they're polyurethane
which is basically plastic
and so that was a wild thing going on
and they kept advertising that the store
was closing
but the store never closed so they said
you're going to get incredible deals
because the store is closing 70
off whatever uh but then this door never
closed but
it also covers some stuff that we never
really got to which i'd like to
to get in with you guys so we're not
covering stuff we've already gone over
uh the valor drone fraud scheme is
something that i hadn't heard of
with kevin zhang check this out zang
falsely represented to the public that
valor drones was an american
manufacturer of drones
in a press release he said that the
impetus to start valor drones came from
the glaring lack of u.s companies
involved in drones a co-founder of the
company explained
when we noticed a giant chinese
companies were the only ones selling
drones
and it essentially cornered the market
and able to charge whatever they wanted
we knew we had to start an american
drone company
so presumably they're making it all in
america
but these representations were false he
sold
cheap drones from china at significant
markups using facebook ads
i can't believe that this is crazy
kevin thing also represented that valor
jones holds a strong commitment to our
armed forces and donates a portion of
all sales
to veterans in need we offer dro
oh my gosh we offer drones a fraction of
the price at our competitors and hire
u.s
employees these representations were
false holy crap if that is
if they have the evidence to back that
up that is gigantic i mean that's
straight up
fraud if it's true i mean if it's true
that's straight up fraud you say
we're made in america you say we're
donating our proceeds to
you know uh veterans and it's a lie
that's
that's crazy it'll be interesting to see
how this plays out in the courts and
that's basically it it's basically this
false advertising
uh that they're getting sued for the
dixon leather thing
going into longhorn leather which is
basically the same website and then
valor drones
if it goes through this would be one of
the first cases i'm aware of where a
fake guru has
really paid the price for their
wrongdoings here
that's absolutely massive and i will be
following this with a close eye to see
what happens
i hope this sends a strong message to
the community that hey maybe
you can't you can't cheat people forever
i don't know excited to see where it
goes
that's all for now i hope you enjoyed
this little update
on evan luther myself my plans to go on
vacation and of course
kevin zhang the guy is in a lot of hot
water right now i would not want to be
him
and uh yeah that's basically it and
don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
lean
comes along